[Applause]
jours beers carnot furry advancing
hallelujah needs a crowd at the ribs who
BOTS with a great defensive effort Kauai
Darlene Popo soaring in with enough ham
talk about going hard to the basket
makes over a half of those little
floaters on the season George left alone
that promotes up three
big body in there trying to affect it
Mavericks with the last six
Paul George creates space steps away and
Kansa 337 percent and a white Leonard
has really struggled this one of six on
the floor he's trying to muscle in
rather than shoot it well Paul George is
knocking a man Jordan with 15 not
tension to the feet turns it over
Beverly in the Clippers have numbers if
they push too George look out below
Stacy look right here as we see you
scrambling the pickoff by stepping up
into the passing lane and then this is a
wind-up throw it down by Paul George
Leonard down the lane muscles up much
shot by the right hand his second bucket
of the night finishes just what he
needed take it off the snide tomorrow
night they'll be in Memphis the right
hand see the post up and the sudden
quick move that time know three or four
dribbles we just clicked to that left
shoulder and then the body moves it
surrounded by defenders late in the
clock now single to cover
[Applause]
with a kiss and a smile knocks it in the
Clippers have 50 points watch kawaii
when he's a to the left show lips is
almost gone behind the backboard the
Clippers lays it in
Clippers lead 59 to 42 first half
leading by 16 against the Mavericks who
come into this game winners of five in a
row Leonard for three
got it
I'm looking around to try to see who the
short person is it's do box its 6:11
George the mid-range shot is googans in
the rebound green screen by his boom box
fries Co eye on the elbow knee knocks it
loose so Leonard to the rack little
right hand and punches it in with a
rebound
it's montrezl running the show galloping
down the lane
rebound Paul George Lee is one quarter
of the NBA population would you know a
thing or two about international play
the wire rattles it
another Madrid shot this time it settles
in for Kawhi Leonard OS 26 12 points for
Brea and 12 minutes and always been in a
problem for the Clippers
Leonard against dodge it into the paint
this sweet spot backs it in what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content